words the silent superheroes of healthy
soil champions of the vermicompost who
with the right conditions turn scraps
into the black gold gardeners dreams are
made of it's a style of composting that
can be done in any space big or small
and costs very little to get started
welcome to the first video of my firma
composting series where I help you get
started with Verma composting and answer
your questions along the way today's
video is all about starting a simple
vermicompost the single total fit now
before we really hop into things here I
just have to say what's up to all 400
plus new subscribers here hello Amanda
from nova scotia Lika from Holland Anita
from Bulgaria this is so cool I love
knowing where you guys are tuning in
from so tell me my friend
where are you watching from and what
should we do to celebrate our next
milestone a 5000 I don't know tell me
what you guys think in the comments down
below alright the moment you've all been
waiting for it for a composting 101 in
this video we are gonna talk about how
you can get your vermicompost set up
really fast and easy from a composting
does not have to be hard it does not
have to be complicated and here to help
you overcome the overwhelm fellow
beginner gardener you can become an
expert from a composter so let's hop
into things
[Music]
so first step you're gonna need
something for your worms to live in
bedding today I'll be using some soil
that you can use compost it's Fagen peat
moss coco coir anything that would be a
good substrate next step you're gonna
need some worms I have some worms on
hand for my worms in the garage but you
can use my links down below to get some
worms from Uncle Jim's worm farm that's
where I purchased them in the past and
I've always been really happy next up
you're also gonna need some source of
carbon I'm using leaves because it's
what mimics nature but you can use
anything from shredded up grocery bags
to shred it up packing paper to
cardboard anything that's been dried up
basically next up you'll need some food
scraps this is what I have on hand I
usually try to go for things that are a
bit more broken down but here's the list
of foods that you'll want to include and
here's a list of foods that you'll want
to avoid adding to your vermicompost
you'll also need some form of grit which
is why I've got coffee grounds with us
today it's a great source of great you
can also use egg shell or oyster shell
and last up you will need a bin of some
kind there are so many different ways to
vermicompost but for today's video I
want to show you just a really simple
one that you can do in just any old
storage tote so we're using this one
hello this is my worm bin now you might
be wondering aren't worms photosensitive
is clear really the best option and he's
in the clear bin because it's not a
stinking have right now
quarantine life you know what I mean but
something that might be cool to use the
clear bin and then you can actually see
what's happening inside it's kind of a
fun science experiment for kids you
actually see what's going on inside to
see all the layers and all of that so it
might be a way to go but just keep it
somewhere dark so that the worms aren't
you know overwhelmed or anything now on
top of my worm bin I've got a homemade
sieve this is literally just one by two
very poorly nailed together here with
some quarter-inch mesh screen on top I
use this to make my potting mix for my
seed starts and I literally will rub the
peat moss on the top leg
and just I'd make it really really fine
and that's actually important for worms
too this smaller the component that you
add the better your worms will do so I
would recommend breaking things down for
worms when possible it's not necessary
but if you're really excited to get
compost quick you can help them along by
breaking it down for them alright so
time to make some lasagna and by lasagna
I mean a worm in but we are going to
make lots of layers as if we were making
the lasagna but with dirt and stuff
we're gonna get your vermicompost bin
set up right now
[Music]
so this this soil is nice and fluffy and
the worms are gonna be really happy to
live in this this is really good stuff
and it's a little bit moist which is
perfect for worms so something like this
texture is really good
[Music]
so something to remember here is that
the more you break this down the easier
it will be for your worms to break this
down and the quicker you'll get compost
I didn't do a very good job of crunching
down these leaves but you get the idea
so by squishing this banana out of the
peel I'm hoping that the worms be able
to break this down just a little bit
easier it was kind of a sticky mess if
I'm honest so it was kind of gross I
don't really recommend doing it like
this but you get the idea the more
broken down it is the easier it is for
them to break it down so that's what I
tried to do even if it made my hand
disgusting Here I am just using my
homemade sieve to add another layer of
getting another layer of leaves make
sure you take out any Trader Joe's
precedes our worms really likes juice
scraps avocado and banana but this is
all I had on hand so I'm adding these
apple and this carrot
[Music]
this parts pretty easy just sprinkle
some grit in there and you're good to go
[Music]
right and just like that we have a very
very very simple firma composting system
set up all that's left to do is drill
some holes some quarter-inch holes
around the top and put a lid on this
thing and you're good to go now let's
talk about some common things that could
happen in this first 24 hours your worms
could be a little distraught worms like
any living creature need time to adjust
and so you're gonna want to give these
worms 24 to 72 hours to get used to
their new environment now with that said
you want to make sure that their
environment is what they like want you
to know how to troubleshoot just a
little bit here in the beginning we're
gonna go nose dive into troubleshooting
more issues later but just in the
beginning I want you to know that the
texture and the moisture in your bin
should be that of about a wrung out
sponge too much and the worms can drown
too little and the worms don't have
enough moisture so you want to get it
just a little damp but not too damp you
need to add a little water you can i
soil and so I know that they're gonna be
happy with that you can do the same
thing and also use moist soil and I'm
sure that your worms will be happy with
that as well thanks for joining me today
you guys that is all I have for you a
very simple introductory video to verbum
composting I hope this video helps you
guys get started of course if you have
any questions leave them in the comments
down below I'd love to help you I do my
best to get every single one of my
comments and as other people here in the
community who are willing to help you
too so feather a great place to get
those questions answered and to find
community is in our Facebook group and
with me on Instagram where we get to
hang out everyday and chat all things
organic gardening home cooking home
setting and all that good stuff
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and share it with your friends
and family on Facebook because that
helps my channel grow now on that note
of growing let's talk about what we
should do for the 5k mark I want to have
a celebration here on YouTube with you
guys live from the garden
right a song named subscribers decisions
decisions here guys when we hit that 5k
mark I don't know let me know what you
guys think down below what should I do
thanks for helping me hit that 4k mark
here's to a 5k and here's some very
healthy very robust vermicompost in
whatever space you might find yourself
from a composting is a great solution if
you've got a little bit of space it's a
great solution if you have a lot of
space because verba composting is so
good for your garden more on that in
future videos if you guys have any
questions leave them in the comments
down below if not thanks for joining me
today you guys it has been great to be
with you and I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]